I made a big mistake in 1982. I won't
take you through it because just to
probably take too long but in other
words a big mistake in 82 when I um
calculated that foreign Banks the
American Banks had lent more to foreign
countries than those countries would
maybe be paid back there was a big debt
crisis I anticipated this debt crisis
Mexico defaulting great okay but what
happened is the economy uh and I
expected there would be a terrible
economic situation and you know what
happened the Federal Reserve printed a
lot of money and it had the same effect
you know you learn the lessons Okay
that's those lessons that I learned
um let me study the 1929 to 32 period
which allowed me to anticipate the 2008
financial crisis on and make a lot of
money there where most people lost money
and right now it's um it what's
happening now has let let Bridgewater
and us to make a lot of money while the
markets are behaving badly now because
the same thing happened in the past so
yes studying history learning the
lessons writing them down modeling them
there's a template of what is happening
there's a story